now then we're joined by baroness
pauline neville jones the former
minister for security and
counterterrorism very good evening to
you thanks very much for being with us
now the report is called a question of
trust to what extent do you think it
goes to reassuring us that security
services aren't and won't snoop on us
unnecessarily
and that there'll be enough checks and
balances in place to protect us well i
think um one of the things that david
anderson's report does is in fact to say
that nothing that's going on at the
moment is unlawful but what he does say
as your report pointed out that the law
which has been amended several times not
easy to follow you have to have a lawyer
to do it it's not clear we need to have
to inspire confidence and trust in the
public you need to have clear law and
much greater transparency so that's one
so let's have a new law in the
regulation of investigatory powers act
um at that area secondly he's saying um
that the
uh and this is a big change and it will
be a big change for the government that
the warranting process should actually
now be carried out in effect by judges
and not by the home secretary on her own
authority she will still make the
application i think
but they will actually be responsible
for deciding whether that interception
that being asked for should take place
and then there is the the third part of
it which um is the um
just frankly what the third thing is but
there is another big uh element in the
in the act uh where i think he thinks
that the
uh powers themselves are you know not as
not as uh well set out as they should be
he also makes the point which is which
is i think going to be a point of
contention for the government um that he
doesn't think that the um case has
really been made for the retention of
data on third parties
and that is part of the data
communications act that the government
does want to bring forward what he's
saying he's not saying you can't make
that case and he's not mean no he
doesn't say that the case is not
justified he does say it hasn't been
made and needs to be made that last
point you made that's the so-called
snoopers charter party that's
making every provider or people that we
use retain
retain data yes so it's about actually
not the information in emails it's about
the um
the wider context isn't it so the
browsing history yes and and and and
there is a real issue here because it's
all very well telling governments as he
does you know that it is legitimate uh
and necessary for national security and
criminal and other purposes actually to
be able to have a warrant to do this
interception what the government's going
to say is that's all very well giving me
that power but you do actually need to
allow me to avail myself for the
information i've got to be able to get
the relevant information so there will
be a point of contention there i think
and the government is what the david
anderson is saying to the government is
you must make this case you must make it
clear to people
why this is necessary so i think what
he's saying is you've got to do
something about this very deep uh
anxiety uh that does exist in some
quarters about privacy about security
and about proportionality of government
power in this area so given that he
obviously thinks the government's failed
to make their case in this matter do you
think the balance has been wrong here no
i'm done well these powers don't exist
at the moment uh so i mean i think what
he's saying is you've got to make the
case in order to reassure people that
actually this is a proportional and
necessary power so he's he's partly in
the game i think a lot of his report in
the question of trust it's about
actually laying down a law and a system
that's really going to command public
confidence and respect and not be
increasingly as it is you know a source
of controversy and of and and the
undermining of trust do you think that
we should be government should be
allowed to collect this data do they
need it well i think i mean i personally
do think that there is data there that
actually you know is is important why
why well because because increasingly
you know um people uh the way you
actually actually get to know and able
to intercept and stop because this is
the problem you know in the past we used
to have crime of a kind you know well
you could deal with people after they've
done something we now have potentially
such horrendous crimes around including
including terrorism and long-stale
long-organized crime where actually the
name of the game is disrupt people and
prevent them actually doing it the only
way you can do that is getting hold of
information you know before they
actually act so you do have to they
communicate on the internet and they
communicate in on social media you've
got to be able no to to be able to
penetrate that but
you know for your my safeguard we need
to know that that's only being done in a
lawful way all only being done
proportionately only being done
necessarily and that i think is what
david anderson is really getting at
let's have a system that really commands
confidence and he is transferring
certain paths to the courts for that
what's your view on the recommendation
to strip ministers of their power to
issue interception warrants and give it
to judges because the prime minister
spokesman's always suggested this could
be problematic do you think well
you can perfectly well you can perfectly
well make a case for for it continuing
to be an act that
that is a political act
um
david anderson has come down on the side
of judges doing it now i would say i
actually support that why do i support
that not because i think that ministers
have abused their powers but i do think
that in the current climate it's very
important to command confidence and i
think that will increase the people's
confidence in the you know in that this
is a properly regulated system he also
said in his report that the agency's
capabilities should be made more public
as in we should know more about what
they do and how they operate obviously
that's going to then give information
out there to people we don't necessarily
want to have that information well then
they can evade the authorities i don't
think he's saying
they should make their operations public
what do you expect
about their activities well up to a
point yes um but i mean there comes a
point where how you're doing it is
actually an operation uh but but people
said that people should be able to
understand what these paths consist of
and what they're used for and why they
are necessary i think all of that does
is there going to be a danger though
and and snowden you know really has made
that necessary
and so yeah i do now i support all that
i think that i think that all of that's
a good idea and i think you know it's
not i'm not a good idea for for
authority to duck the issue uh we do we
do need actually to have this debate
okay neville jones thank you very much
for your thoughts thank you